well a short time ago king charles and
camilla the new queen consort left
balmoral castle to return to london
earlier prince harry left scotland after
rushing to balmoral reports say he
arrived after buckingham palace
announced the queen's death there will
be a series of carefully planned
memorial events over the next week or
more starting in scotland elizabeth
palmer is in edinburgh where the queen
will lie in state elizabeth good morning
good morning the queen died in scotland
at balmoral her country estate which she
particularly loved her body still there
but it will be driven roughly 100 miles
or so here to scotland's capital
edinburgh and to the royal residence
that you can see behind me holyrood
house
plans are still fluid but in the coming
days the procession will take the coffin
to saint gelse's cathedral where members
of the public will be able to pay their
respects
after that the queen will be flown to
london
britain is in official mourning and
palace officials are planning for 50 000
people a day to file past the closed
coffin which means lineups three miles
long she'll lie in state at westminster
hall in the parliament buildings for
four days and then another procession
will escort her body to westminster
abbey nearby for the funeral
she'll be buried in the st george's
chapel in windsor castle next to her
husband prince philip who died last year
meanwhile charles iii is traveling from
scotland to london today to be
officially proclaimed king tomorrow he's
now 73 years old the oldest new king in
british history
but he isn't actually likely to be
crowned until sometime in 2023. tony
that's the ceremony liz palmer forrest
in scotland liz thank you very much